forbes has come out with a list of the
highest-paid actors and actresses and
there's some really really interesting
stuff here so let's take a look at the
five highest-paid actors and actresses
ok so number one for the women Sandra
Bullock she pulled in 51 million dollars
last year Jennifer Lawrence 34 million
Jennifer Aniston 31 million that one
kind of surprised me because she doesn't
seem to be doing that much Gweneth
Paltrow 19 angelina jolie 18 so the top
10 females added up to 226 million
dollars were just showing you the top 5
there and then for the men Robert Downey
jr. 75 million dollars Dwayne Johnson I
mean I just saw GI Joe to really 52
million dollars Bradley Cooper 46
million Leonardo DiCaprio 39 and Chris
Hemsworth 37 million and the top 10 men
added up to 419 million so I'm going to
start where you brought us Nikki before
the show started you brought up an
interesting point about box office you
want to bring it that first and then
we'll go from there I I'd be interested
to know like what Sandra Bullock has
brought in in terms of box office
numbers vs Robert Downey jr. because if
they're both relatively the same and
that and Sandra's still getting like
half the amount of money that Robert
Downey jr. is getting then that's you
know that's really an imbalance but if
Robert Downey jr. is bringing in twice
as much to the box office and Sandra
book then I look at that and I go well
if he's bringing in a billion and she's
bringing in half then yeah you should
pay her him more right so--okay so we
don't know that specifically i think
it's i think it's a great yeah but so
just using the information we have
they're still does seem to be an issue
with yeah there sure in there yeah come
on ladies fight for your women here
what's
if Robert Downey was pulling in twice
the box office I think the more
fundamental problem is that the movies
that are being written are being written
for leading men and so yes he's going to
be pulling in more box office if the
scripts that are out there and available
and the movies that are being funded are
all movies where men are the leads right
and this is a this is historic in
Hollywood like I worked in the sciences
for a long time before i came into
production and i started working in
front and behind the camera and i would
people talk about sexism and stem all
the time right science technology
engineering math and how women don't
have the opportunities that men have and
how we're working really to push through
the glass ceiling and when i got to
production i thought it would be a
relief oh my [ __ ] god is it it's
almost worse it's almost worse than
Hollywood than it is in the sciences
women don't have as many opportunities
available to them so if they don't have
those opportunities they're not gonna be
able to get the box office which me and
grant it we're talking about people like
Sandra Bullock who still made like what
50 million dollars like all right I
don't give a [ __ ] right but if we if we
actually translated that down to the
camera operator that was gonna say later
the two women who have a chance I mean I
work on a show we're finally this season
we were able to get some female
directors on the show yeah but we had
besides the Creator herself we had not
had any in three seasons female
directors and it's like where are these
women they're out there but they're not
getting the same opportunities DPS yeah
especially knees camera grip yeah like
you just delivered it right I don't know
you really don't so late that's where
the big struggle is I do think that how
much though is is that women don't
necessarily gravitate to those jobs I
mean are there are there a lot of women
that want to be yeah kind of a work yeah
yeah yes they're actually I had a female
um jib operator on the last show like I
did a daily live show on pivot for
almost a year and the jib which is one
of the hardest cameras opera it's really
heavy she was female she was amazing she
obviously wanted to be in camera off I
just don't think also I don't think the
society says like that's a job you
should have as a girl like as a girl you
should be in front of the camera or your
drone or wardrobe makeup yeah makeup am
I can show you they're almost always
women yeah yeah for the record our
director Amira is a girl and she's
fantastic
well say I do i do want to say that i do
think it is changing in terms of women
lee female leads you know Hunger Games
is a good example Sandra Bullock in
gravity angelonia Angelina Jolie and
every action movie she's ever done I
think that it is changing it is getting
better so that's that's that's something
positive i also i don't i would what I
would like to know what the
International value of the those men are
as opposed to the women because that
also could have something to do with it
females like morning ideals well no I
mean in terms of like it does box office
internationally like you know our people
internationally more likely to go see a
Robert Downey jr. film then they are a
Sandra Bullock film or a Jennifer
Aniston film you know Dwayne at Johnson
he's really big internationally so why
well why does because I wrong hands big
as life and there's a lot of explosions
but that I think is part of it that's a
lot of this isn't all equal information
because if Robert Downey jr. is an iron
man people love going to those math
versus gravity which I absolutely loved
but a lot of really slow okay let's show
you have to look at the whole let's look
at all the action heroes out there you
have to put I mean it's newsworthy when
there's a female action hero a comic
hero and oh okay now we're gonna make a
movie about that but like most of them
are men I mean just right now used to
look at every billboard here in Los
Angeles for expendables 3 there's about
87 men anyone oh there is one concoction
I forget her name she was actually they
did a Wonder Woman pilot and she would
that fail they tanked but I think it's
her that's in there so I was looking at
it it's not a huge building on Sunset
Boulevard I was like oh look at all this
men and one woman that's hilarious
because I've seen anything that's is
that what we're talking about I mean
I've seen that probably 50 times and
every time I'm looking is there a woman
in her a woman is
how did also kelsey grammer how did he
become an action star he motions well so
now he's in it so I don't know how that
happened last night on this just the
numbers you know we say these numbers 50
million 75 million but like it's nothing
like these people are literally making
more than we all make like in ever in
our whole lives yeah I don't know which
workout but they should should they as
an actress okay because we make a lot we
make those companies very very rich yeah
we make those companies very very
wealthy and it is it's it's Sandra
Bullock Sandra Bullock is selling that
movie people are going to see it because
she is in it yeah you know so she should
get paid a lot of money because if you
knew the kind of money that they are
making on the other end you'd be like oh
well then yeah she should be making that
amount of money for carrying a movie and
making itself right but is there a point
where is there a point where they priced
themselves out because i went to see
Planet of the Apes last week and
literally a popcorn and a soda was more
than the ticket you know to be like is
the rest of that where people are
eventually you're gonna be like you know
what I'm just not gonna go spend we're
seeing what I mean because I do think
that we've got our priorities a bit
unbalanced in this country and I do
think that it's a bit weird that Sandra
Bullock makes 50 million dollars in a
year because but we do that we make that
decision no it's the same thing with
professional athletes like they make so
much money it's insane huh and then
you've got you know obviously he
responds back in like PBS you know like
here comes the NPR like Social list over
here but like yeah exactly first
responders teachers you know whatever
visit like they don't they don't make
nearly the same kind of money um I think
you're right Sandra Bullock deserves
that given the current landscape I think
the current landscape is weird and I do
think it's kind of cool that we're
starting to see that change you're
starting to see the rise of the YouTube
star you're starting to see the rise of
the individual self made Oh a person
it's shifting it really really really is
shifting where people can make a web
series and own their own
10 and that is power now and they can
you try to live off of it like it is not
all over LA we're seeing these like
co-op kind of places pop up whether
these writing studios and these kind of
produce where people own their own
business but they don't want to buy a
whole store front and they don't want to
work in an apartment so they pay like
200 bucks to be a part of this group and
they can go have a desk and and the
reason that is happening is because so
many people are making it they're
actually making enough money to get by
on their own as an entity I guess I
guess from me I think you know I add you
have to look at it in the context if
you're making a movie that's going to
gross 50 you know five hundred million
dollars or whatever it is and you're the
face of that yes you should get a large
percentage of that but if you're making
an indie film and you have no idea what
its gonna make you know and you just
want to do it it's a great script you
want to do it you get scale and you show
up and you do your job or a hundred
dollars a day and then you say hey I'll
take two percentage points of the back
end if this thing ends up doing really
well because yeah I gave you my face I
did my time but you don't have to pay me
up front I think that it it is in the
context what movie are you making what
is gonna be the box office and if you
keep bringing the money in you should
get paid yeah that's what being an
artist is all about right you do some
stuff for money and you do some suffer
but that's all yeah really good to fine
I know I gotta I gotta keep it short but
like I was the other day I was talking
online about how I want to get an
electric car and I was asking for advice
and every response was get a tesla model
s it and I was like I feel like I
shouldn't have to point this out but I
keep [ __ ] and I literally got
responses from people like you're on TV
and you can't afford that car yeah and
I'm like I just think that there's what
ends up happening is that Sandra Bullock
makes 50 million dollars and so people
go anybody who I've ever seen in front
of the screen is rich yeah and what they
don't understand is in a movie like that
two people get top billing they might
make five million each and then
everybody underneath it makes like eight
hundred a day and caicos one last point
i'm sorry i love how to defensive
because also all of our money goes away
we get paid ten thousand dollars and we
get a thousand dollars of it because we
well there's taxes okay and this is like
half which is like laughs because they
think that you make that year round and
you don't you make it you a prat one
rule yeah and they're like oh you make
that out here so we're gonna take half
of your money and then outside of that
you have to pay a lawyer and you have to
pay an agent inactivate manager then if
you're on a show like me you have to pay
a publicist and then you have to pay a
stylist or jealousy showed up yeah
that's pretty good yo she's working you
like and so I'm just saying like the
amount of money that we have to dish out
to actually just do our jobs yeah is
insane all that being said all that
being said I want 1500 that means that
we're still very lucky to be able to
have a creative job where we have a
creative a job we love where I can at
least make rent yeah like to me it I
make rent and I'm about to pay one
hundred ninety nine dollars a month for
a lease on a new electric car and I'm
very happy that I can afford me again to
breathe I'm getting I think a chevy
spark and it's so cute as a spark that's
the new electric it's very cute Oh John
how to roll the dr son oh there you go I
don't know regular tyt of you for the
record I do want to just say I actually
am in the one percent it's the other one
percent close i'm actually closer to
that one percent certainly than the
other one but you put you wear it well
hmm
you